if one person listening to this podcast
tomorrow sets up a meeting with their
actual boss
and actually delivers what's on their
mind that may save them
for being able to stay in a company they
actually like a lot of things of
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience podcast
friends how are you uh very excited
about this
as all of you know i'm not doing a whole
lot of original
um interviews these days kind of busy
head down but uh
very special guest here uh um in a
second i'll let him i'll let beth really
introduce herself in her own words and
i'll go into a series of questions but
uh this has been a long one in the
making that i'm excited about
and hopefully a lot of people get a lot
of value out of it so
without further ado beth why don't you
take the floor for three or four minutes
here and give everybody a little 4-1-1
on what you and your sister and
organization do a little bit about
yourself and then we'll we'll go into
some q a
all right sure hi gary hi everyone
listening i'm beth weisenberger
co-founder with my youngest sister
lauren zander
of handel group we built handel group 17
years ago
and it was our first year like is there
such a thing as executive life coaching
17 years ago we were made fun of we were
not you know the first question out of
everyone's mouth is
are you a doctor and we're like yeah no
we're not
we are executive life coaches and we
gave ourselves a year
to see if we could build a company or
not and here it is 17 years later
we're the largest executive life
coaching company and we have about 70
people who work for us
and i coach c-suite executives like gary
so yes i am gary vee's coach um and
about 21 22 other executives
leadership um executives in his org and
then about
total of about 500 people are engaged in
the coaching in one way or another
through interview or one-on-one coaching
and that is what i do for a living is i
go into companies triple their
businesses
and raise the bar of humanity and
learning to
human better um with all the people that
we coach so that's me in a nutshell
prior to you and your sister going into
this let's go back to
little beth i always like to do a little
you know
a just to paint pictures for the
audience like what kind of
girl were you growing up like creative
were you athletes were you
were you student where did you grow up
give us a little context i want to get
to
i want to do i want to do three minutes
to the moment of you and your sis
and then we'll go into you know
executive coaching and
common themes we have a lot of
entrepreneurs a lot of executives who
listen to this
so i want to spend a lot of this on
common themes and i'll go into it
you know one of the breakthroughs no
question that i think you've been
instrumental in
for vayner and me uh but let's go let's
go
a little bit further back like to my
childhood yes so i
was raised so i'm 62 years old i'm the
oldest
of three other siblings um my brother
matthew
my sister marnie and sister lauren we
were
raised as i said orthodox jews in long
island so i'm from the five towns
lawrence
none of the four children turned out
orthodox jews
um we honor spirituality and i you know
i dig being jewish
about as far as it goes my father is 85
still a modern orthodox jew mother never
really was
um she told us the secret she was
keeping
um for 50 years is that she never cooked
you know you're not supposed to eat
um dairy and meat together and my mother
said confessed
to my father oh i always cooked with
dairy and milk
it would only make it better and all he
did was
spit his food up he laughed because you
know what's he gonna do they're 85 years
old now
i love it i um was an athlete i was
number one on my tennis um
team volley uh you know in high school
volleyball team track meet i did all of
that
um when i was older um my daughter had
me um start riding horses at 50 years
old so i rode for eight years
and um and now i water scheme my
boyfriend made me get up on water ski so
i do that too
what about from a student or
entrepreneurial lens
horrible bad girl do not anyone my
lesson in life was if i could do it
again i would do it better
you know in high school i had to i was
punished by my parents brutal
brutally if i didn't get b pluses
anything less than a b
no sleepovers no phone calls you know
for me
right so i was bro i was punished
constantly
oh yeah i was i was grounded literally
from fourth grade to senior year of high
school
i stayed grounded yeah mine was although
i never tell the act the accurate story
because i used to say my mother used to
hit me
which she did but my mother had five
rules
the fifth rule was if you don't follow
the four i'm gonna sock you
so she won right i was the rebel i was
like yeah
you i ain't listening to you and so i in
high school
obviously i wanted sleepovers and a
phone so i
kept the promise of replacing by the way
for all the kids that are listening the
phone was not the mobile phone
it was having access to water
bring it downstairs and plug it in the
basement so no one could hear you right
and then um college i finished i started
university of michigan
and finished at nyu i studied to be an
actress never did that
um how was michigan was that a fun
experience or did you
talk about fun year and a half um i was
there for a year i did college in three
years so a year and a half
there love did it was [ __ ] cold as
goddamn hell
um but you know i loved the football and
i loved all that stuff i got out of the
small town and got far away from my
parents
and then i came back to nyu and
graduated there
is that because you wanted to do actress
life and you needed to be in new york i
was going to be an actress and daddy i
need to be at nyu
right so you know spoiled total
royal brat that i was and you know my
poor dad i i have apologized
and i would never do it this way again
and
just for my own fun because now i'm
enjoying myself here
when did you when did you realize
actress life was not how quickly into
that journey did that happen
that i ended that at about 21 i
graduated college and then i got into
the whole world of humaning and
transformation and wanting to save the
people and so i left acting right away
interesting yeah what uh
talk to me about your sis because i know
this offline a little bit your sis
came like was doing her thing like give
me there's a lot of
lauren xander yeah lauren xander is 11
years younger than me
she is no kidding um the genius she is
the chairman to my vice chairman in the
company
i'm running the company day to day uh
she is my boss
deserves to be my boss and she invented
all the method that were teaching at
vayner media and you know and
um and all the different companies like
nation and
insurance companies is all my sister's
method that she invented
and then i took it and figured out how
to get it grounded and
sold you know to clients
big ones talk to me about let's jump
around here a little bit so
tell us you know she comes with this
stuff you guys sit down
you decide to start this business yep
a lot of people who listen to this also
want to be in the service business like
hey
hire me to do x whether that's be an nft
artist right now
whether that's to be a content creator a
consultant
how did you get your first clients
[Laughter]
raid making baby it's rain making you
know my sister and i are rain makers
right so
you know we were not we had a method my
sister's method right
and then we were just we had a rolodex
we did not believe in cold calling we
did not believe let me go cold call all
the linkedin connections i got
we're not that gang right like you you
meet us
you love us you want our method we're
getting in and so we
really were um all our relationships
is who we you know went and spoke to and
when we got our first big corporate
client
um we then knew we had to deliver and we
tripled his business
and then it just became word of mouth
we're still in the word of mouth
business
um in the company that we're in we're
i'm not gonna have people cold call i'm
not that girl right so it's all
relationship building
so i get my job done with you garyvee
and then
someone's gonna recommend or hear about
that and then they want to know
can you do that for my company of course
always worked like that
so literally again because what i try to
use this platform for is
really help the people on the other side
okay you
you believe 17 years of success that
when you have a quality product if
you're able to
you know remember you and your sis
had a rolodex to kind of tap into
from your years of doing whatever you
were doing in the past
you were able to kind of land you know
in that
in that networking of the people that
you've had relations with both of you
you're able to get one of those several
dozens of people
to say yes you were able to execute thus
it created leverage for word of mouth
going forward
yes you're uh what would you say to the
person that's listening right now and
saying beth
i've got the husband like you me and my
sister just like you guys
but we're both 25 and we really don't
have
that much of a roll of dex and thoughts
on that just out of curiosity where yeah
one thing that we believed that we did
right like what got us
into mit so we wanted to make a
difference in the whole
university world education world help
the students help the administrators
and so one of the ways that we worked is
we would go hey gary you're a professor
at mit we knew that
this professor happened to want to get
married and had an
awful love life my sister said all right
i'll coach you on my diamond get you
married you get me into mit
and they made that deal and we got in
same way we got into stanford
and we teach there for credit now right
same way um and most of the corporations
in the beginning that i got in
i would either with the president or the
head of hr
your you know your chief human resource
officer um
or someone accountable for marketing i
go
let me give you 30 minutes or an hour
you see
and then tell me if you want to bring us
in so we
stay there for a second one thing that i
hear a lot about is people
um demonizing free work
and and you just you know put it on a
pedestal curious
to you know i'm sure you've seen this
over the last five to seven
10 15 years there's a lot of
conversations like never do spec work
never do free work it doesn't seem like
you know i'm not on that camp
yeah no if you're 25 years old and you
say you have a product that rocks
and you want in my business i'm not
going to pay for it i don't know you
you don't come with anything so give me
a trial and then if i love it i'm going
to
i'm going to want it i'm going to tell
my other people about it so we were
what do you and what do you say i got
some of my biggest
nfl players was like let me give you i
don't want
they all think i'm going to come for
your money no i'm going to give you two
free sessions and if you like what i
just gave you
then you then you buy if you don't like
what i gave you what's the big deal you
got two free sessions i met an nfl
player
i made a difference but guess what every
nfl player that i ever gave two free
coaching sessions to
my clients beth what about the people
who took three sessions
and didn't become clients what do you
say i
send them away with love they don't
either have the money
what i did they didn't like who cares
that was 30 minutes
out of my friggin life maybe an hour
out of my entire life that i gave it
away i believe
in sorry it's weird but i believe in
paying it forward you pay it forward
it's coming back
now i don't pay it forward to get it
back
but why wouldn't i do that like if i
want to start in this
if i want to build a sports division and
i've never done that before
like i could say well it translates from
business to sports now i know it does
but
the athlete doesn't so let me just
do this for you and i that's how we
started our business
and it worked and here we are for the
for the
individuals who um
who have companies yeah
and have 6 12 22
212 employees let's rattle off
in this podcast themes that you
see that are
common i want to say universal because
every situation is different but there's
a lot of commonalities yeah these things
what are some of the things that you see
that are common
in companies that lead to
bad cultures or vulnerabilities or
limited growth
well i'm gonna say one of yours you
ready
i'm ready all right so i know you gave
your culture a b
minus and so once you know we raised the
bar
and now it's a b minus okay far out so
then what's in there and so
last week i did a session with nick
and a bunch of his svps on removing
gossip from the workplace gossip
is one of the main culprits that if you
do
not remove it from your culture and then
put in how do you have hard
conversations
so we can talk about klein candor but
you got to teach people
how do you do candor right like if i'm
not gonna gossip
and talk about you know go to somebody
who can't do
anything about it and tell you crap
right i gotta take that out but then i
gotta teach you
go have the courage to go have the
conversation whether it's with garyvee
whether
it's with this executive or this person
so
gossip is one of the main culprits in an
organization
give me i love that and i couldn't agree
more give me
give me a couple more because i really
want people to leave here with like
huh that that is going on in my shop you
know
what are what talk to me about actually
let me throw a couple things at you and
then you'll add
what about insecurity of upper
management
when you hear that how does that play
out in your mind so if someone comes to
me who's like
ins has a whole negative dialogue about
the leadership
before i'm gonna go anywhere near the
leadership you know i really do believe
in accountability so
what is this human why is this human
sitting around
complaining to themselves and likely
other people
about they're not digging on the
leadership all right well what the frig
are you doing about it
so i would start with there being what
we call a chicken and avoiding the
conversations
i would then help them to stop being a
chicken and and script the conversation
that they have to go have with
leadership right like so if you've got
your junior people talking trash
about the leaders it's twofold you got
junior people being chickens not able to
go speak to them and then leaders why do
you have people so scared of you
that they can't come talk to you so it
works both ways they don't feel safe
enough to go up and then i'd have to
talk to the up the leaders and go what
are you doing not making it safe enough
for people to come to you to let you
know what's not working
but from your perspective all these
years what perce
this is such an arbitrary question and
you'll do your best to answer it but i'm
really just fascinated
what percentage of companies do you
think are being led by
fear and what percentage of companies do
you think are being led by
optimism and offense and trying to
eliminate fear
just from your perspective through the
years i'm just curious
all the doors that you've brought you
see i think no matter
in every company i've been in and like
i've told you i loved that you had
created in your culture the honey empire
right
but we had to deal with that it was a
lot of honey and not a lot of us you
know
can you to your point earlier the big
breakthrough you've done for
you know me which you know has is a
really important part like this
this term kind candor and to your point
now we have to
operationalize it but even in standing
up
and having an entire company meeting and
explaining to everyone
you know back to accountability hey i
have very big ambitions for our culture
we've done a lot a lot of things right
by standards one of the biggest
compliments in my
23 years of operating was your
assessment when you came in and said hey
you actually have a lot of good [ __ ]
going on here you know and
and our our entitlement and our you know
my inability and this always blows my
fans minds i always tell them i'm like
public figure me great at candor because
there's no human on the other side i'm
speaking into truths right i'm speaking
on stage
so garyvee brings a lot of value to
people calendar-wise but
gary vaynerchuk the ceo
really struggled you know and and you
know through another
part of my life i was able to realize my
dad's
negative vessel to delivering candor was
what i was
not fond of the the energy of the candor
i i had to take years to separate the
vessel from the actual thing
candor and and the way that i've tried
to position it kind candor
i think is now an essential element of
our culture and is moving us
up um we needed that bad
um and it's really made a huge impact
um but uh but i think it's always
interesting to see
what commonalities and shortcomings
companies have yeah let me give you
another one so another one
is um and again in your culture
and i'm starting to work on it with your
executives and will with you
in our coaching session tomorrow is that
the language of accountability
so garyvee you got a language for sure
for um wine right so like there's
languages i don't have any language for
wine i go
i like it i don't like it is the extent
of my language
the language of accountability is
very important in fact i think that's
what will impact the empire side of your
honey
empire what i mean by the language of
accountability first and foremost
is the ability to own when you're not
going to keep a friggin promise
that does not make you a bad person
at all it depends on how you own it
when you just blew a promise so if you
blow a promise i don't want to hear
gary i didn't do it i said cause you
know this happened
and this and they didn't return my email
and then so there's
no like there's just hi i know i said i
would do that
i didn't do it that is clearly
unacceptable here's what i'll do about
it
here's when it will be done and did
you know i'm a little concerned that i'm
not going to be able to deliver on this
exactly on
wednesday before the deliverable is due
on
friday even though i know you're hoping
you will get it done and that you won't
get in trouble and it won't
no one then says on wednesday okay
listen
i'm a bit i'm behind i'm messed this is
dude friday it's not gonna happen
here's what i'm gonna do about it did
that mess you up
etc so there's a language of owning
when you're not going to do what you
said even the ceo
gary every ceo is allowed to change
their mind you could have said
i love changing my mind right i know you
do but you
i i do i mean i know but you have to be
able to own it rather than explain it
because at the end of the day no one
wants to freaking hear your explanation
about
why you just freaking changed your mind
again or are not going to do what you
said
they just want to be able to hear beth
listen i know i told you i was going to
do that
not going to do it with you
but here's what i'm going to do about it
and then let them speak so there's a
language of accountability that's
missing
in most companies love that beth
how many people end up
leaving companies that were actually
good jobs for them
strictly because they were unable to
have the proper conversation
you know when when i think about all the
people that have left
you know i i get it on the receiving end
i get people that
email four or five years later that
regret leaving
because they didn't take care of one
little thing that became a big thing
you know and by the way by the way i
have enough self-awareness and
accountability to know that if i didn't
have the luxury
of being a ceo and like being a
business owner my lack of
wanting to have confrontation and candor
would have meant that i probably would
have been that kind of employee that
[ __ ] things are it's easier for me to
move on
then i mean i think i think about it in
a lot of parts of my life when i was you
know
why i broke up with girlfriends as a kid
when it could have been addressed but
because i didn't want to address it
yeah you know so what when you when you
hear me frame up that question cause i'm
trying to think about
like there's a far majority of people
that are listening right now that are
employees
that have little micro problems and i
just think that whole framework that you
and your cis have around the chicken
could be stunningly impactful on if one
person listening to this podcast
tomorrow sets up a meeting with their
actual boss and actually
delivers what's on their mind that may
save them for being able to stay in a
company they actually like a lot of
things of
yeah i feel that a lot of people leave a
lot of companies
or let a seed become cancer
please yeah let me address it so it's
actually
and i've done this with a bunch of your
people it's in inner you in module seven
it's called career haunted
why don't you tell everybody how you
expanded your business to not just be
human but
platform yeah so so let me let me answer
this and then i'll tell you so this is
i'm speaking about everyone inneru
which is our online coaching module 12
modules so interview
life career love student we have
different ones
but in module 7 in the career one it's
a career haunting now what's a career
haunting
it's something that happened so let's
say however old you are you've had a
million experiences
and when we ask you for your career
haunting let's say you've got
five to ten of them the question is why
does that haunt you
and the other 999 000 experiences don't
because the way you tell that story has
a lie in it
or you didn't learn the right lesson so
the and
most people the right lesson is
speak up use your voice why did you let
that person do that to you when you
didn't say anything and then they leave
the job
and you learned the wrong lesson called
hello use your voice
go ask your boss why did you do that
when you said you were gonna do this
like there's a conversation and so the
hauntings will keep
happening to you in your life over and
over until you learn the right lesson
beth how when people come to you and say
beth i hear you
you shoot it straight i love this set
you know
long island
you and gary spent you know if they hit
you up on social or something for this
you guys spend a ton of time on shooting
it straight and the candor thing
which makes sense because that was such
a big framework for us
we had strengths but this was a weakness
but
but [ __ ] that you two were wrong i shoot
it straight all the time
and i'm always getting in trouble i'm
always getting fired
yeah the person who's listening here
that
that i got yeah because i think it's
gonna help because
i i've noticed that yeah let me finish
this because i think you got me but i
want to make sure everybody gets it for
the person that
hears this and says well this is the
wrong advice i've had a very difficult
time in my career because
i've been fired multiple times because
the boss doesn't actually want to hear
the truth
what's the common mistake for the person
that finds themselves cancerous
what are they missing you're missing
empathy you're missing the kindness side
you're missing your heart
you can't hit somebody upside the head
with the brick with no heart
you'll leave them bloody so even though
your message
might be accurate if you do it with a
punch
with no kindness and no empathy and no
caring about the human
high you kind of deserve the smack right
easy easy easy for people who are bosses
or leaders or
owners thoughts for the people a lot of
times i find
that employees don't feel they need to
do that because the machine
the bosses have the leverage do you
you know i've noticed you know i've
tried to coach and
talk to a lot of like i'm like look just
because yes
you're a junior employee bricks still
make bosses bleed too
correct incorrect what are your thoughts
oh you can't you'll get it's disrespect
i'm the boss gonna feel disrespected
right and
or that you're not loyal or whatever the
pet peeve is for that boss there's no
you don't ever want to disrespect
someone it's always
how can i let you know what isn't
working for me
from my heart so you can hear me right
and then we can have a conversation
people it's not you know your boss your
manager
they care about you i know you've come
up with whatever
story you now believe and gathering
evidence for
but you're gathering evidence and you're
going to be walking right out the door
so the main principle is whatever you
believe you prove
if you believe your boss doesn't like
you
you're going to keep proving it and
therefore you won't go speak to them
so you don't want to get stuck with that
belief because likely
it's not true even though you're
gathering evidence for it
the last three minutes of this podcast i
want to give you the platform a how can
people find you because i know plenty
well
b what did we not touch on that you'd
love to touch on okay great thanks gary
you can find me um at handel group beth
p-e-t-h
at handel group h-a-n-d-e-l group.com
um and then you can just shoot me an
email or a note you can find me on
instagram handle group you'll see all
our content
and go on there because we drop content
all the time that you can listen to
myself or any one of my coaches and help
you
whether it's in a you know you'll see
like today i'm going to be doing
boundaries around saying yes it is a
nose
um and then the other thing everyone of
course for gary's listeners
um and gary's got about 500-ish people
in this program it's called inter-u it's
our online
coaching modules our coaching course and
for the listeners
you can get interu life for half off up
until march 31st so for 325
it is a genius course it's our whole
entire coaching program
and you get one free coaching session
with it not me but one of my coaches
um and use the coupon gary who who
should they ask for
on the one coaching thing no you're not
them okay all right just having a little
coupon garyvee the half off okay
you created something so there's a
garyvee for that gary thank you
absolutely nice yes all right
all right i'm coming for you tomorrow in
your coach i know i'm looking forward to
it
team everybody's listening look i've i
i in another life will be able to like
have beth at her sister's job i love
this [ __ ]
and i think that for me through the
years i've been able to do a ton of this
stuff insular
but there's just something so incredible
with different terminology different
voices different energies
it's like anything in life and i think
the more everybody
starts to expand on on that awareness
like no matter how good you have it it's
like anything else
it's good but there's always it's like a
seesaw there's always the
other things that come along with that
good in vayner land
over the last 20 years it's been really
good by macro comparison
but candor was an incredible the
important one and standing up the term
kind candor made it even more palpable
and scaled and there's plenty of more
things but that's for an instance
so hope everybody continues on their
journey beth thank you so much you and
the handheld group
for the impact you've had on our org
other orgs and i hope this podcast
leads to a couple other people getting
uh getting some uh
advancements in their journey i know
you're in costa rica so go enjoy the
weather
thank you for being on bye-bye thank you
so much bye everybody
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider
it and i hope i see you soon